well the information we are having right
now is that approximately one hour ago
with strong explosion in the gas factory
east of the city of Lyon there were a
couple of wounded people and there has
been one person decapitated on the
premises of the factory his hat has been
a couple of yards from his body there's
been one person arrested he was
allegedly carrying a flag of Islamic
state and he also said that he was a
member of the Islamic state there are
several people wounded and well the
information is coming through right now
it's very fresh so it's aprox apparently
a terrorist attack in the east of France
especially in the region of Leon the
security has been stepped up in the
region around Paris and also in
Marseille a large city in the south of
France but not in the region of Leon of
course the authorities in France are
always counting on new terrorist attacks
there is a lot of security in place
everywhere but indeed this yep you see
factory is a new target a new kind of
target compared to the terrorist attacks
we have seen a last January in France
indeed well that was the journalist
effing Devrie talking to as from Paris a
short while ago the friend